jean-pierre corps ne vaut a longtemps
été considéré comme un ou dix ont
illuminé
à 12 ans il s'est lancé un défi sauver
le château médiéval de ricou en 1932
son grand père paysan a acheté une ferme
quelques hectares de terres agricoles et
ses ruines envahit alors par la
végétation
je promène mon chien que je me pose la
question du regard les les tourelles les
taupes avant et je me dis qu'on bien des
choses se sont passées ici encore été
construits vraisemblement dans la
seconde moitié du deuxième siècle
il se composait de deux de deux courts
une cour d'habitations ici de l'autre
côté de ce rempart une cour d' une cour
de ferme
l'ensemble était défendu par quatre
tours carrées donc de existe encore il y
à 25 ans déjà un reportage montrait la
restauration en cours
la famille core nouveau mesure ainsi le
travail accompli l'actuel propriétaire
succède donc à une lignée de nobles
connu comme nicolas rolin chancelier de
bourgogne au xvème siècle
ça vous embête pas de pas voir le
château termine non donc est ce que
j'aurai à faire après 25 ans plus tard
la restauration se poursuit toujours
avec l'aide financière de l'état de la
région et du département de haute saône
prochaine étape cet automne la chapelle
puis les deux tours carrées
c'est des chantiers qui pourraient se
dérouler dans les années 2020 2021 donc
c'est plus seulement des rêves ça
commence à devenir un peu des projets
c'est vrai qu'il ya une urgence sur les
tours carrées non seulement elle ne pose
quand même quelques soucis de ceux de
solidité mais aussi ce sont des endroits
qui sont extrêmement rares trouver une
tour carrée du 12e siècle entière et
dans son état de construction d'origine
c'est très rare donc à protéger
absolument et si on peut les rendre
accessibles
pourquoi pas mais là c'est la cerise sur
le gâteau on vous présente le lieu
d'après une maquette ainsi que
l'extérieur a écopé jonnier et après que
cette visite écrite vous allez à votre
rythme à sauver le château jean pierre
cau renouveau est en passe de réussir
son pari avec un objectif supplémentaire
le faire connaître
le château de riz cours est le quatrième
lieu le plus visité de haute saône avec
plus de dix mille entrées chaque été
cette entreprise et familiale premiers
soutiens colette son épouse une
parisienne de passage en 1976 quand on
épouse jean pierre on épouse forcément
le château d'eau ricour à mais c'est une
évidence
l'un ne va pas sans l'autre bien sûr
c'est on peut pas séparer jean-pierre du
château dont on comprend tout on prend
rien et vous avez tout pris et j'en suis
heureuse aujourd'hui dit vrai que un
jour je mens bien reprend louis
en tout cas si vrai que au stade actuel
je ne peux pas concevoir
de vivre sans ce château ça c'est ça
c'est sûr la famille core nouveau
considère que sa mission sera accomplie
quand les murs d'enceinte et les tours
seront protégés le château d'eau ricour
avec ses dix siècles d'histoire pourra
alors envisager l'avenir sereinement
[Musique]